blake shelton and gwen stefani are one
step closer to saying i do
on wednesday the singer made an
appearance on today with hoda and jenna
and shared when he and gwen plan to tie
the knot hopefully this summer
now you know i think we're right here at
the point with
with kova dislike it looks like it may
be okay but i don't know so
uh that's tentatively the plan
so we'll see blake also revealed that
he'd rather marry gwen
sooner rather than later i'm afraid if
if she and i wait till
next november then i'm right back into
the voice
cycle again and uh really want to be
able to have
plenty of time before and after it's one
of those once in a lifetime you know
moments and speaking of the voice blake
also said that there just might be a
wedding performance from his co-stars
miley cyrus and adam levine
you know it started to sound like a
coachella
lineup here all of a sudden i've got all
these superstars standing on to it
i'd love to to be able to take everybody
up on their offer we're just waiting
every day just like everybody else to
see what our summer is going to look
like and then go from there
blake and gwen got engaged in october
but have been together since 2015.
the pair has never been shy about their
love for one another i think somebody
that can make you laugh
constantly is very sexy and
somebody that is let's see
humble kind down-to-earth
selfless talented on the top of their
game
should i keep going before the two
started dating gwen was separating from
ex-husband gavin rossdale
while blake was also going through a
divorce with ex-wife miranda lambert
both of our lives had basically fallen
completely apart
and and little did we know it happened
to both of us
at the same time and we bonded over that
and then
you know it's so somewhere in in that
you know that
time of of just you know darkness
was this ended up being
the greatest moment of my life you know
so it's just it's amazing it truly is
blake also admitted to hoda that he's
ready to live a simpler life with gwen
outside of the spotlight
i mean we've both pretty much
you know taken it to the limit as far as
you know our careers go
and and and uh touring and and now
the television thing it's been fortunate
to accomplish a lot of things uh but
hopefully at some point we'll get a
chance to live some life
and i think we're both ready for that
[Music]
honestly
you